jeff the drunk you're on the air hello
i don't want to end up on the street
what you're not going to end up on the
street you live in america where
uh we we um give you money not to work i
don't get known
as just money because you're making so
much money on
cameo because you know i reported
my income like i should
right and they covered me up jeff's also
going to something called toycon
in vegas in july to do signings out of
booth so he'll be there
really jeff also claims he's going to um
make people show proof of being
vaccinated before he takes a picture
with them
so there's a whole thing there might be
a protest there where
people are protesting that they have to
you know be vaccinated to be near jeff
bring your id [ __ ] right
okay there you go by the way i'll also
be appearing
at trailer con drunk con
unemployment con and i'll be giving you
imprints of the boils on my ass for 250.
nice wow did you see that what fred's
holding that's a jeff the drunk puppet
it's really funny
uh we have to show that one